I want to get to an important aspect of
our Public Health
and our specifically Mental Health Arena
not transgenderism I know everyone talks
about transgenderism all the time but
this is more important this is
fat phobia this is trans slenderism if
you will a mental health counselor has
gone viral saying that if you are fat
and you lose weight
why you're fat phobic another great
question this person was asking if there
is any time in which intentional weight
loss is not fat phobic
I certain I'm going to say 99.9 of the
times
if you are intentionally losing weight
it is fat phobic I'm leaving that point
little zero one percent in case I am
truly truly wrong but I don't think I am
and here's the reason why I'm not saying
if you exercise
and happen to lose weight that that is
fat fat phobic
I'm not saying if you start a medication
and you happen to lose weight that is
fat phobic I am not saying that if
you're going through any type of take a
drug it causes you to illness and I'm
not saying that's that altering your
body in some way that that is fat phobic
I'm saying when you are intentionally
exercising to lose weight altering your
diet to lose weight doing any activity
intentionally to lose weight is fat
phobic I still can't get over if you
take a pill and you go through a medical
treatment that causes you to start
wasting away I guess I won't blame you
for that I guess that's not totally your
fault but if you ever want to lose
weight so that you are less obese so
that you're healthier why
that is fat phobic the irony is that the
people who accuse others of phobia
are always the ones denying rationality
a phobia is supposed to be an irrational
fear but it's the ones who accuse people
of a phobia they're the ones who deny
rationality I don't even just mean that
they are unreasonable they're obviously
unreasonable people but I mean they deny
even the possibility of rationality
because I can make a rational argument
and say well when when you're morbidly
obese that can have all sorts of
terrible effects on your health and it
also is spiritually disordered if you've
got a problem with gluttony you probably
are going to want to address that
problem and so in order to be physically
healthier
to become more spiritually disciplined
to not hoard resources for yourself even
to to
um have a more healthy relationship with
the physical world
um you should lose weight
they say how dare you
or if what about the transgender phobia
what if I make an argument and I say
that look I'm using my reason and I
think men and women are different and I
don't see how your true identity could
differ from your natural biological sex
and when you look at the rates of
depression and anxiety and suicidality
after the so-called transgender
reassignment surgery actually none of it
improves and on one measure according to
the largest data set on this ever on
anxiety things actually seem to get a
little bit worse and so for that reason
for many many other reasons which are
philosophical which are anthropological
which are biological which are
psychological for all of these reasons
transgenderism does not appear to be
true
and they would say how dare you how dare
you bring up reason and logic they they
are the ones who deny any recourse to
reason because what but what they say
when you ask them for a logical argument
for their beliefs
is they say well there doesn't need to
be a logical argument
because it's just my subjective feeling
when you propose a debate like we did
two days ago at the University of
Pittsburgh the very last minute even the
top Scholars on this stuff are going to
drop out they're going to drop out
because
the real the real phobes the real people
who are being irrational here and who
are they're phobic even of rationality
itself they are they are the libs that's
what they do right now go to
goodranches.com enter promo code and
also if you've not changed the way you
buy meat yet you really need to let me
tell you three reasons I personally
subscribe to good ranchers first good
ranchers is giving you free bacon for a
year
pound and a half of bacon in every box
it's a 240 value second good ranchers
offers a price lock guarantee meaning
that when you subscribe your price does
not change for the lank of your
subscription when the price of meat is
expected to increase by another four and
a half percent in this coming year I
don't even understand how the financials
at good ranchers work but it could be a
huge huge savings for you and your
family third good ranchers meet is just
better it is just better objectively all
of the others they're all natural
burgers or sweet little elise's favorite
they're USDA prime steaks so we're
talking really top grade stake here
better than organic chicken it'll change
your standard for great meat I I am very
picky when it comes to my food you know
I'm an Italian extraction food means a
lot to us good ranchers is second to
none absolutely Peerless in the space
and the prices are better than anybody
too goodranters.com use promo code nulls
for 20 bucks off your box free bacon
great meat a secure price and a bonus 20
off today promo code Knolls at
goodranchers.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered now another
viral Tick Tock I do want to get to
before we go this would be
a black lady who really doesn't like
white people can you imagine here's why
I don't trust white people I don't trust
white people for a multitude of reasons
but one of the main reasons is they're
unpredictable like I think about all the
times where I really considered white
people my friends and then when we got
in a small argument they released all
the racism they hid throughout our whole
friendship
scary and then I think about the fact
that I'll be here
what what does that mean
because that
that would be odd if you were friends
with somebody and then the moment you
had a little tiff over I don't know
um hey let's split the bill no I'll pick
up the bill or you had a little tip over
I want to go see this movie no I want to
go see that movie they just started
saying you n-word you have you put on
your clan hood or something like that
yeah I don't I don't
believe that has ever happened
now does she mean that when she and her
white alleged friends get into an
argument
uh the very fact of disagreeing is taken
to be racist because that's how the libs
argue today the libs argue today and
they say if you ever
just disagree with a black person you've
got to be racist if you ever disagree
with a transgender identifying person
you're a
transphobe if you ever disagree on any
topic if you disagree on the idea that a
man can become a woman you're you're a
phobic of some kind
I suspect that strongly
what is implied here keep going well
give them the opportunity to come clean
about any problematic past they say
nothing and then they get exposed for
being racist and it's never like some
low-key like I used to say the n-word in
songs no it's like n-word hard or
against black people like like tell me
why white people are normalizing racist
past
also I think about the fact that way
people have continuously when given the
opportunity oppressed multiple
marginalized communities and I think
about the fact how easy it is for them
to do it again like if they really want
to they would bring slavery back they
kind of already did with the criminal
justice system plus the right of hate
crimes
I will legit always be scared of white
people until they're the minority
which I hope will be sooner than I think
so what is she going to do then
what if white people became the minority
and this woman wants
a an explicitly racial form of the
justice system
what happens to the white people when
that lady's in charge
you see the flaw in her argument of
course she says
that white people all they want to do is
oppress black people they're just so
oppressive that's why they have
affirmative action that's why they keep
pushing these crazy reparations policies
that's why they have all of these these
rules that's why they don't when BLM is
riding around the country they don't
punish them at all but when a Yokel and
a granny show up to the Capitol on
January 6th they throw them into
solitary confine them just because they
want to oppress the black people so much
if white people are the majority of the
country which This Woman's lamenting
then why aren't the white people doing
that now why aren't they bringing
slavery back now she has a little
parenthetical she says well they sort of
have through the criminal justice system
so she's saying if you punish criminals
you punish robbers and murderers and
killers
than your
that's the equivalent of slavery so
she's giving you a vision of the
Criminal Justice System under her
preferred world that would be a criminal
justice system in which white people
can't do anything right
in which the the jails are emptied
criminals are let off the hook
it would be a criminal justice system
that is explicit about punishing people
for their race we have a justice system
right now that that does actually punish
people for their race it punishes white
people and Asian people if they're the
wrong race
and those are the two wrong races then
they have a harder time getting into
college they have a harder time getting
jobs and if you're a part of a favorite
race then you have an easier time having
those things
and and
what this woman is saying is well once
I'm in power we're going to turn that up
to 11 baby I don't know that doesn't
seem great that doesn't seem like a
great idea hey smash that button am I a
cool hip Zoomer YouTuber yet I don't
know but you do have to subscribe you
get a ring that Bell hit that button
because we have a lot of great content
that is coming out here on YouTube so go
check all of that out get the show every
day we'll see you later
[Music]
foreign